qu'est ce que tu vas chanter joris on
s'embrasse on oublie tout on va j'ai dû
me tiens allez moi la noce marocaine
ouais frédéric soit attentif
son caquet
tu pleures parce que tu es content
et alors c'est vrai c'est qu'on en est
là qui je vais dire alors tu vas te
pleurer davantage alors parce que il ya
plein de jouets il faut pas pleurer
comme on est heureux font rigoler il va
voir comment tu rigoles comment on fait
pour rigoler regardons vu comme ça
comment fait on rigole simple comment
fait pas rigoler ça fais moi un sourire
pour moi c'est pas malheureux de chanter
parce que tu es content de chanter
ballon chantes tu veux frédéric françois
données codées toi tu veux chanter tout
seul tuvalu normalement la voyais
allemand revient à malien
il pleure parce qu'il est heureux mais
il a besoin de vous voilà le frappez pas
avec ta maman tu chantes ça mais
touchante l'admettre à côté parce que
mtv a été troublée
là
où
non je sais pourquoi
ben non on va pas écouté et on va pas
faire pleurer on arrête ta nea donner un
sucre aux basses et voilà que tout ce
qu'il faut tout ce qu'il faut heureux
fais moi sourit alors la troisième
concurrente
toute souriante elle envie de rigoler
comme moi c'est sandra numéro deux en
applaudissant radio 2g d'apple semble un
numéro deux que ce que tu vas bien
on se dit bonjour j'ai aussi fait un
bisou et où tu viens là mais moi ça tu
habites dans un pays où on fait du
chocolat oui est ce que tu en revanche
beaucoup
tidjane jamais de chocolat c'est vrai
quoi qu'est-ce qui fait on va pas y
travaillent dans le chocolat
bah ça c'est un beau métier
alors là ça me plairait d'avoir un papa
qu'ils soient agents voyage parce que
c'est pour tuer déjà voyagé
vous savez que c'est sexy qui est très
malheureuse pas de chocolat mais il s'en
va aurélie notre avant dernière
candidate qui a beaucoup de mal à
descendre jeter dans une capitale
allemande
et aux imams que tana
elle a fait une bise à l'autre
pourquoi qu'embrasser le petit garçon
est ce que
café tu viens madame un pis tu dis non
voilà et toi qu'est ce que tu veux faire
de sa grande oui
qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse la
dépouille de m
alors qu'elle s'en sont une charte là
allez donnez moi la première donne vas-y
les chantiers où les enfants sont avec
moi elle a le discours
tulle avoir la télévision mireille
mathieu masseau va pas souvent et les
jolies oui marierait bien avec elle ah
oui famille
pourquoi excuse j'ai même qu alors
libera bijoux se lève trop attention
restez sérieux à tanger les fiançailles
alors qu'est ce que tu nous chante
nicolas tous les aveux sont pas les
maths et uc guèye a les yeux là tout cas
on m'a toujours dit quand son talent et
son port en faisait chanter le monde est
roi
la troisième candidate et l'élégance en
personne c'est marine est vrai qu'ici
mon papa maman avait permettez que je
fasse connaissance de la famille
c'est à fiancer oui c'est ton fiancé
alors pouvez vous en passer
pourquoi parce que aller boire encore
marié et commentent commençant ses
parents il est trop sympathique
oui ta belle mère est gentil très bien
maintenant belle maman reprend les dont
le mari
et puis vu avec qui on papa et ma patte
à puteaux il ya mieux
et m'a dit de venir maintenant j'attends
mais que vous m'appelez et ça fait trop
longtemps
et qu'est ce que tu sais faire o sinon
une école maternelle
là tu peux m'aider là je vais vous allez
un peu mais dit je viens pas vous aider
vous avez bien sûr ça comment tu
t'appelles nicolas femme si on attend
alors tu finis je finis avec avec
geoffrey et tu restes là tu vas bd1 tu
avais dit que tu mettrais oui alors
c'est toi qui devrait poser les
questions à ma place c'est vrai qu'est
ce que tu voudras faire quand tu seras
vétérinaire c'est très bien
tu peut pas soigner les anime oui ça
bien et nous allons accueillir cette
ravissante vanessa regarde comme elle
est jolie fait une grosse bise à
philippe là et vous l'applaudissent et
transport
regarde on aurait dit que j'avais
préparé le micro pour toi qu'est rescue
à vanessa
c'est dedans et toi tu es française oui
est-ce que tu habites villiers sur marne
ont tué pas venus de très loin qui est
venu en famille où tu venu tout seul
enfin alors qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ta
famille papa et ma maman bon papa et mon
parrain où il est ton papa c'est le
moustachu un oui ça pique ses messages
qu'ils appliquent pas anti pas assez
démoussage hippiques paris
les papas en toujours des moustaches qui
piquent pas comment il s'appelle ta
maman koering bonjour corée ils
travaillent tous les deux marques
we have fun parce que vous étiez des
frères et des soeurs une petite fille
unique
oui ça te plairait d'avoir des frères et
des soeurs combien tu en voudrait ma
chérie une seule voie là est ce qu'il
vous reste à faire un jeu vous aurez le
bon de commande à remplir toutes à leur
dit non j'ai l'impression comme ça que
tu fais un peu de danse parce que tu as
l'air bien tu fais un peu de danse non
oui de la danse classique coûte fema
voir comment s'est montré moins vraiment
un petit peu de temps ces mots voir
comment fait de la danse rythmique
comment comme ça
je vois comme ça la danse tu fais tu
fais de la danse rythmique et tu veux
pas me montrer
alors tu veux chanter quand même oui
qu'est-ce que tu vas chanter oui j'ai
dit voilà emilie jolie c'était celle que
j'attendais parce que je la chante tout
le temps passer
je m'appelle emilie jolie je m'appelle
et me dit jeudi
je voudrais partir
et vous vous dites sur moi même et je
voudrais demeurer gauche
mazet
tu t'appelles emilie jolie
capelli
j'ai envie
tu es parti
tout est aujourd'hui
aernout paris
il va nous arriver
piqué louis
quant à elle emilie jolie
tu rêves de jolies
me rejoindre
l'allemand nie tout s'est tu
m
allah
t'es qu'un ami
non
n'y a pas match
département le virement
non pas du tout
ta vie ne fait pas
attachant
m
qui
de temps lui
bon là non ça change tout c'est bien
voir c'est ce que me disait une autre
changement lui disais cette critique
chant très très très juste tu fais de la
musique
abbas et pour ça c'est une petite pièce
on l'applaudît très fort et on lui donne
une note
attention philippe très attentif à ce
nouveau paquet de seurre cédric tu
choisis ce que tu veux à voile à thème
bien manger
qu'est ce que tu aimes le mieux - attend
alors oui surtout bas c'est normal
et puis ramasser dit cassé les dents et
je fais toujours la nuit mais il fait
d'ailleurs la musique à fumer tu fais la
nuit là c'est vous pourquoi ça c'est
marrant c'est pour ça que tu as tué
parce que ça fait péter oui j'y pense à
eux quand même et ça c'est marrant oui
ya que toi qui ça arrive dans la famille
à qui est-ce qui pète encore reaap
impeccable
à l'école je mange à la cantine où tu
manges ces mamans aimerait donc à
l'attenté et puis je mangeais l'équipe
frêche et mamma mia la cantine qu'est ce
qu'on mange ce qu'il veut pas pas comme
métier
wild eyes les rouleurs et maman qu'est
ce qu'elle veut mais si la machine papa
et rouleur et la machine à quoi tu as
compris au moins tu es tout seul août
les petits frères des petites heures
1 3 kopecks frissons
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les frais de ce nom
d'un repas et pourquoi tu en veux pas
parce que tu as me plaît pas déjà parent
fiscale
dernier candidat y aura bien lieu oui
sans tes parents bonjour monsieur
l'électricien et moustachu dont la bande
moustache ça j'ai vu lé 15 cm aux
syndicats mais je la vois je n'avais ni
allah ni ne voulait pas qu'on sache que
porte des lunettes alors elle les a
enlevées voilà pour lui remettre
maintenant un ipad et lui met d'habitude
hélas les avaient enlevés pour pas qu'on
voit qu'il porte des lunettes et
drôlement gentille comme maman comment
c'est son petit nom
bonjour s'il vient n'est pas pas comment
jean-paul il a une bonne bouille
jean-paul il boit de l'eau du vin j'en
étais sûr c'est un copain à moi combien
il boit par jour 2 3 de prague
c'est un combat
toilettes un joueur entendu deux chevaux
dit toi tu vois pas demain maman boit du
vin un peu
combien de litres monsieur christophe
pour l'applaudît tréport alors viens là
christophe quel âge tu as aussi
longtemps que je fais c'est un peu le
micro à 6 ans voilà très bien ça va
là-bas l'auteur l'a fait un essai enfin
laissez là dedans à dire un homme
politique
est-ce que tu regarde la télévision en
ce moment j'aime bien regarder la télé
alors qu'est ce que tu en penses tous
ces hommes politiques qui n'arrête pas
de parler tu sais faire les pépés du
mauvais tu sais moi voir comment ils
font
faites moi un gros plan sur son autre
artiste poète - voilà est-ce que tu veux
me refaire le ppd va pas parce que moi
j'ai pas entendu
vas-y tu as fait appel full web et les
méthodes cette tâche et c'est le moins 4
e quai c'est certainement le plus grand
la haye à n'en pas douter c'est l'aîné
oulala qu'il est grand temps qu'il est
grand ou qu'il est grand c'est eric oki
les grands eric
on applaudit eric
qu'elle a su à eric c'est quand combien
cinq ans au parti tôt cinq ans au assez
facile étonnant alors qu'est-ce que tu
es grand pour cinq ans je vais voir ton
papa s'il est aussi grand il est très
bien à paris les entends papa est plus
petit toit tourner les tout petits il
est très grand combien il mesure 5
mètres
c'est un monsieur vous devez avoir du
mal à vous habiller en confection ton
papa mesure 5 mètres et dammam en six
mètres
et bien dites moins chère madame voilà
une grande invite alors dit bonjour et
tu as un frère tu es tu n'as pas
vraiment pas de soeur vous êtes une
grande tué un chien
les combinés mesure l'autre troisième
candidate
mademoiselle sylvie que je vous demande
d'applaudir bien porte bien merci
alors tu es venu tout seul où tu es venu
avec ta famille avec ma famille alors
dit moi ta famille qui s'est passé mon
papa et ma maman et mamie alors 806 part
en lambeaux et comment il s'appelle papa
papa l'a dit freddy je leur ai dit
qu'est ce qui fait comme bédié voie
d'arrêté
est il normal de trois joueurs du so ici
des femmes
allez jean ii makoun dit
oui oui comme s'il est donc non pas
madame marie voit quelques fois fait
peur
ils boivent dépeinte à la gendarmerie au
début leur à ses débuts
on a produit très fort benjamin voilà
benjamin veste j'ai monté le migros
maintenant quelles astuces à benjamin 6
à 6 ans 6 ans a bien fait voir presque
toutes tes d'enfer gros sourire
construire la caméra ailleurs manque de
mon papa il m'a dit que tu me fais pas
trop sous rien à y faire
à cause de quoi tout enfant n'ait pas
peur même si tout sourit si tu savais ce
que tu es beau quand tu souris fait d'un
grand sourire tient la caméra en gros
plan allez vas-y bien de veiller à son
papa et qu'est-ce qui fait ton papa
comme métier est-ce pas peur des impôts
mais un inspecteur gentil
bien sûr ces enfants j'avais dit frère
de tuteur non mais j'aimerais un petit
frère tout de suite oui voilà bon je
t'embrouille pour la semaine prochaine
oui y'a plus de goutte qui tombe d'un
un cas jugé avec qui tu es venu avec ma
maman papa vous fait voir papa alors les
gouttes
qu'est ce qui fait ma part comme métier
mamie nova et les schémas mais demeure
il fait des yaourts bon sens qui
l'appliquent août
les boutures manouba a raison mais ça
compte dans le vent tout seul
stéphanie qu'on applaudit bien fort
tu viens de 7 mais c'est un pays que
j'adore et avec eux qui dieu venu avec
mon papa ma maman et moi
les mamans travaillent et l'hélicidine
svc maman moi et ça paraissait modique
qui fait qu'il veut faire le mien mais
comme papa congé d'un mois il s'éteignit
pas pas couché dans son lit
oui mais moi j'ai coché dans l'élite et
ma maman à est ce que tu vas à l'église
jamais ta prière petit jésus je vous
donne mon coeur j'ai pas qui c'est le
petit jésus
il habite pas cet âge ils habitent 7
sarah jane très bien j'ai tout de suite
vu que c'était un garçon que l'as tu
attends moi dis donc
et puis je vais te dire j'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un avoir des gros bras comme ça
tu fais du sport toi qu'est ce que tu
fais comme sport
savoir comment tu en fais quoi là
repro fait voir aux puits vise juste
justo fois qu'est ce que tu as for java
relativement c'est la même langue
c'est ton petit frère cadet et alors est
ce que tu le bosc est lui aussi ses
bosquets ya alors c'est toi qui gagnes
tu viens voir je l'entends h ensemble
les deux parties vient vers toi qu'est
ce que tu attends une seconde non vous
n'allez pas poster quelles valeurs il
disons qu'elle bosse keur madior jus à
la base que tous les deux qu'est ce que
tu chantes comme chanson passé faut
regarder ça on va l'écouter cher
vas-y 1 2 3 ou là ou là oui bah vous
comprenez c'est sensé comprenez c'est ça
allait bien vas-y alexandre 1 2 3
je vais te dire hé ben ali daei la casse
tony rhin est-ce que tu suces ton pouce
alexandre s'est promis ça t'a jamais su
si ton pouce qui met quant à toute la
nuit
ah oui et voir comment tu fais assez
drôle ça c'est pas ton pouce que tu
suces ac les deux doigts du milieu très
bas c'est la première fois je vois ça tu
sais sifflé tu peux me siffler culture
voilà un garçon complètement complet
alors qu'elle est l'heureux possède où
sont tes parents je suis qui lèvent le
doigt
attendez à quoi il ressemble et
ressemble à rien jean-paul j'ai dit que
tu étais mon copain parce que j'ai vu
que tout à l'heure tu savais faire des
grimaces
oui est ce que tu veux me faire quelques
je vais essayer de refaire la même
tu me diras si c'est bien non on va
faire un concours de grimaces tous les
deux et c'est le réalisateur qui juge à
toi de commencer vas-y j'en fais une
autre
comment tu la trouves bosch magritte
assez moche tu es mieux ne tienne toi ma
jean paul ii parmi d'autres je vais
essayer de la faire
comment tu trouves match qu'est ce que
tu vas chanter
à ses parents
mais non c'est pas grave
de plus
bon
euh mon pantalon kaki un elfe attaque ou
ne m'a pas sur mes chaussures si je
monte comme ça on ne se voit pas du tout
cas fait pipi
puis tu sais les chaussures ça va cesser
nous fasse et je crois pas et des
chaussures vans doit céder chaussures en
carton oui enfin ça va tu as fais pipi
maintenant tu es tranquille
alors qu'est ce que tu chantes qu'est-ce
que tu es un génie et ben vas-y chance
quel succès très haut que tu es grand
pour quatre ans et demi et où est-ce que
tu habites cédric qui habite en france
quelles rues
rue de la butte celtic en france tu vas
à l'école cédric donc tu vas commencer
simplement tu as pas encore été et ça
fait plaisir d'y aller j'aimerais mieux
rester à la maison avec maman elle à
l'école tu es tout seul tous les petits
frères des titres
trois copains f par un seul
wako par un terrain et vous jouer tous
les quatre ensemble et sa soeur elle est
plus grande que le même âge que toi vous
êtes né le même jour où sont tes parents
a très bien comment elle s'appelle ta
maman
son petit nom bonjour jacqueline et ton
papa luisi ap joseph p c'est un prénom
italien sa vraie vitalien tu manges des
patchs étoiles tous les jours
pas tellement tous les jours alors
qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
serais tu attendais ça c'est la première
fois que j'entends cette profession là
on va l'écouter attentivement [ __ ] tu
veux être quoi ma propre impuissance pas
si c'est un métier formidable ça tu sais
déjà faire des maquettes de vaisseaux
spatiaux
alors quand il sera grand tu voudrais
lui dans la lune ça te plairait d'être
un cosmonaute et de monter dans le ciel
pourquoi tu sais pas trop piloter un
vaisseau spatial
mais c'est très facile à prendre
tu sais faire des sons spéciaux en lego
bon alors c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
commencé à cap canaveral
tu as dis bonjour à françois à françois
excuse moi tu vois ça tu me pardonneras
parce que j'ai connu ton père à l'âge de
ce garçon voilà tu as dis bonjour à
monsieur chatel à monsieur philippe fut
une grosse bise
il vient qu'est ce que tu vas chanter
cédric le hérisson et commencer faire
hérisson ah bon tu en as déjà vu du
nourrisson a alors tu va nous chanter le
hérisson est invasive
bon ok ce qui pique un somme racer
hockey mehdi lacen chanson honte et qui
piqua même ce n'est un seul
ok et puis sa chanson
c'est un hérisson stars sont si bixi
piqué échoué qu'ankara ça se fasse car
ce papa papa pas ce que dit pas mais
parce que piquer ses heures sont
typiques et hippiques et et qui grince
machine car c'est à santa matin lorsque
je parlais mais parce que piquet prison
l'écrivain sa chanson
2 on y met mais papa papa la rue près à
ce beau film d'horreur locker l'asepsie
delà de la rivalité petit et après après
la veille avait mis date une dame k par
les pluies y avait une dame qui quittent
et qui fait mal leurs vieilles c'était
une raquette 15 à la vie est plus la
date nathanaël aligné comme sa grosse
que moi moi tu as eu peur n'avait pas eu
peur parce que j'aime bien les films
daraa
on a vu un peu même cas pas eu peur y
avait un pistolet lycée pascal était ce
parce que à l'asie il a dit avec colère
pour rien faire il avait il a fait un
saut cas que la comcom et là nous
il laisse du sort elle est plus elle est
pétrie de brûler la renier ni la grosse
araignée
à la fin elle meurt et b monclar et 10 à
la fin c'est pour pour pour essayer de
les attraper les attraper dans le feu
qui a collecté peas en cours ils ont
fermé la porte
chris levée c'est bien ça beau fils on
peut la police
après la halle afin que tous les petits
la ville avait elle avait là et quand di
nolfi qu'avec avait un coeur rouge and
bike la traite
après seul quoi là c'était marini
l'africaine de petites araignées et puis
voilà
bonhomme comme c'était comme on fait il
est tombé 10 classes temps mais on va
trouver mais qu'ils étaient amarrés la
tombe et me l'avait dit l'était pas
marre mais elle seule pourra se croisent
à ce coup là les souterrains john cale
goût pour la retrouver à citer des noms
ça mais c'était pas d'aimer sans cette
salle olympique qui cherche la renier
cette crise car ennemis alors à la ronde
la douleur
ok c'est la rue qui appelle est très fan
heures ils étaient 120 jours de
fermeture sont diane madame c'est
l'effet ni soy la panne ont dès le début
si et puis il était mal à l'aise de
compter du 6 bravo tu parles tu connais
tu peux me chantait voilà elle n'a pas
fait une seule fois qui d'alsaciens pas
une seule parole à l'ats qu'est ce que
tu dis il n'y a pas de faute dans mon
texte alsacien n'y a pas une seule ford
d'alsaciens et lyon mais ça se danse ça
et voir comment ça parce que moi je
faisais là c'est votre moi
retournez redonner la balle
en
c'est très bien vous est là dans cette
logique si on n'apprend pas à johan
wickman mois métier tu veux faire un bon
me why we et ben oui je me trompe comme
la twa habitent ou à pantin
commencé pour les jo mais jolie carte
postale
et ben voilà s'il veut il peut traduire
présent la galette